bon ben les fédérales sont derrière nous
et on ne donne un résultat trois
rivières tout à l'heure ce ne soit rick
s'est allongée et là on entre de plain
pied
dans les municipales anie samson luc
ferrandez bonsoir
il le combat entre madame plantes
monsieur coderre si on en croit ce
sondage vous montre sondages le devoir
léger ce matin 500 personnes qui ont été
interrogées c'est chaud est-ce que ça
correspond à ce que vous sentez année
autour de vous si ce que je sens sur le
terrain pour me promener un peu plus
jaser avec les citoyens en tout cas
chose certaine le au moment où on se
parle aujourd'hui dans les 6ème ma
semaine qui commence personne ne peut
prédire ce qui va se passer honnêtement
la personne je gagerais même pas une
pièce sociaux parce que c'est trop ça
bouge trop et les cartes dont des
positions tellement différente qui vise
pas la même clientèle donc le défi ça va
être la sortie de voie ça va être
quelque et en t elle va aller voter
parce que les clientèles plus jeunes
celles de 30 ans et moins ce n'est pas
nécessairement celles qui veulent plus
voter et c'est la clientèle de madame
plantes tandis que l'autre côté c'est la
clientèle de l'équipe de dénis coderre
et luc ferrandez on l'a dit au fédéral
on le dit
lors de notre campagne ça montre que les
campagnes vont être importants la
dernière fois monsieur coderre avait une
campagne du fil dentaire là il faut que
les deux faces une bonne campagne oui
parce qu'il ya matière à inquiétude
aussi bretagne indiqué matière
inquiétude pour madame plainte parce que
sont votés et concentrés dans les 18-35
matière était aussi pour monsieur
coderre parce que le taux de
satisfaction est à 48 % pour
l'administration aux plantes ces postes
suffisant pour se présenter en héros il
faudrait au moins 60% pour dire j'arrive
puis je vais vous débarrasser de cette
personne alors ce qu'il doit faire c'est
une campagne positive axée sur ses idées
déposer des idées et c'est parce qu'il
fait jusqu'à présent il critique les
idées de valérie plantes mais des pauses
peu de ces idées là il faut qu'ils
changent il faut pas que tu attends même
campagne que la dernière fois sinon il
va passer à côté on va les écouter sur
ce sondage on vient te suis
écoutez les sondages c'est sûr qu'on les
regarde
je comprends aussi que 33% des gens
seulement qu'ils veulent que
l'administration actuelle demeure faut
travailler 1 puis on n'a jamais dit que
c'était pour être facile je vous ai dit
depuis le début que si je prenais rien
pour acquis il va avoir des mais je veux
qu'on fasse une campagne d'enjeux et de
locaux tb une stagnation j'ai envie de
dire même une descente parce que au
final mon opposant a perdu une dizaine
de points là ce qui est somme toute
énorme donc je pense que les gens
réalisent que
monsieur coda est revenu en disant j'ai
changé chez un homme nouveau mais je
pense que les gens la balloune dégonfla
les gens ça rend bien compte que c'est
c'est le monde le même bon vieux denis
qui fait de la même genre de politique
un peu à la pièce
selon le gré du vent
c'est madame plan qui fait des
personnels
passants c'est une attitude que valérie
a souvent eu un conseil est très très
combative là c'est paul c'est pas le
temps c'est le temps d'être de parler de
ces enjeux de ces propositions
magnifique proposition aujourd'hui sur
le logement il faut continuer dans ce
sens-là logement police centre-ville
mobilité c'est là que ça va être
intéressant de les entendre posture le
crêpage de chignon peapod j'ai la banane
comment j'avais réagi mais moi non plus
- les campagnes électorales surtout
municipal cd campagne d'idées les jeunes
audois on le sait le pl et 200 m peut
aussi que les deux sens bon de chacun
chacun et bongrain qui se regarde dans
le miroir mais ce qu'on veut c'est
savoir qu'est ce que les citoyens vont
avoir de plus en votant pour un ou pour
l'autre qu'on se lance la chine hôte
comme ils font là ça donne absolument
rien au débat ça ne fait que dire aux
gens restent à maison par les pauvretés
il faut trouver des raisons justement
donc le taux de vote de participation
augmente en leur donnant des promesses
ou des choses qui vont faire sont aussi
réalisées madame plantes propose on va
les écouter rapidement mal un plan des
réactions monsieur coderre 60 mais
logements abordables pour lui dans les
dix prochaines années on est quoi si
dans les années 80 une mesure comme ça
avait été fait jeudi dans les 85 90 ou
2000 mais si on ne mesure comme ça avait
été fait plus tôt mais on n'en serait
pas on serait déjà dans une meilleure
posture que maintenant
la priorité numéro un c'est vraiment la
question de la sécurité mais c'est la
sécurité de son logement également donc
c'est d'avoir un toit sur la tête et
puis on aura des annonces à faire en ce
sens
il a dit par ailleurs que c'était
irréaliste selon lui anie samson commun
comment vous jugez s'être promesses et
engagements écoutez il ya une promesse
mais aussi une promesse qui a été faite
en 2010 et celle de douze mille
logements 6000 signal social puisse
signer l'abordable sa peau était
atteinte donc les 12000 qui sont là
n'ont pas encore été atteints moi quand
je vois seul c'est de la poudre aux yeux
le site marchand de sable qui passe en
10 ans les électeurs on a des choses à
vous donner regarder 800 millions c'est
gros puis 60 mille logements c'est
beaucoup 800 millions c'est sur 40 impie
les logements sur 10 ans 40 lc8 mandat
électoral donc aujourd'hui ma la plante
s'engage pour les huit prochains mandats
à hypothéquer les autres qui vont se
présenter avec un budget de 800 millions
y avez-vous pensé là c'est immense sur
les douze meilleurs ça pas fonctionné
actuellement le il ya encore des gens
qui vivent la crise du logement qui sont
hébergés dans des hôtels au lieu de
penser à ce qu'on veut faire dans les
dix prochaines années je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on devrait régler le
problème des hlm il ya quand même 500
hlm qui sont des des logements dans les
hlm qui sont barricadés qui doivent être
rénové au coût de 10 millions il y en a
encore dit milk sont vêtus c'est encore
des gens qui restent là qui doivent être
rénovés fait que je me dis c'est beau
rêver mais aujourd'hui encore des gens
qui en ont besoin aujourd'hui demain
matin puis encore des gens l'hôtel qui
n'ont pas de logement je vous dis que
c'est là dans ce formidable mais
plusieurs précisions apportées d'abord
que le logement à langer de logement
complètement changé de statut par
rapport à il ya cinq ans quand monsieur
coderre est en poste on parlait du
logement comme pour les familles
démunies maintenant c'est tout le monde
qui n'a pas il n'est pas établi qui peut
avoir un problème de logement c'est très
très difficile de pouvoir s'installer à
montréal à l'époque monsieur kadhafi
avait 3 millions sur l'ensemble du
mandat pour l'achat de terrains madame
plante a quand même mis 10 millions par
année ça fait une différence c'est vrai
que y ont pas livré les 6000 logement
social parce que il ya eu un blocage
québec ottawa montréal mais c'était
peut-être est prévu un prudent de le
promettre sachant que québec et ottawa
est impliqué maintenant pour les
logements qui s'en viennent ce ne sont
pas des logements sociaux ce sont les
logements abordables donc c'est un
principe qui s'appelle la cola
lens 3-1 en anglais en français c'est la
propriété la copropriété du terrain ou
un organisme achète du terrain construit
puis quand la personne achète sa maison
il achète maison mais pas la valeur du
terrain et quand il revint il revint
avec un peu moins de profits donc se
presser plus que précieux cumulatif
taser plus la coop la société qui va
faire ça va en faire et en vente plus ça
va avoir deux capitales alors c'est vrai
que c'est imprudent de faire une
promesse sur 20 ans mais
messi le principe mais rigide comme
jamais l'idée vous mais oui parce que ça
existe à burlington bernie sanders là ce
soit dans les années 80 il a développé
un million de logements dans le vermont
de cette façon là donc ça existe ça a
été essayé je comprends pas pourquoi
montréal n'a pas fait plutôt bien tant
mieux s'ils commencent bon c'est vrai
que c'était imprudent de faire des
grandes grandes premières salles 800
millions mais au moins ce début on il
faudra que chaque odeur arrive avec ses
propositions la tiu chi définitivement
c'est une bataille entre les deux on
sait le logement c'est une question
primordiale pour la campagne électorale
et pour que les citoyens aient voté il
va falloir qu'on compare les deux
programmes parce que moi vous savez je
suis apatrides gp de partis politiques
donc je regarde correctement ce qui se
passe mais quand on lance la pohdh aux
yeux comme ceux qu'on lance des gros
chiffres depuis que je sais qui encore
des gens qui vivent à l'hôtel parce
qu'ils n'ont pas de logement je me dis
un moment donné les priorités faut les
mettre aux bonnes places c'est beau
rêver mais faut pour rêver il faut qu'on
prouve qu'on a été capable ivry ce qu'on
avait promis avant et c'est là c'est là
où moi je pense qu'il faut aller
chercher nos citoyens par des vraies
choses 1 et locke merci beaucoup on va
accélérer nos rencontres au cours des
prochaines semaines merci beaucoup
jusqu'au c'est avec les membres et vous
serez d'ailleurs jeudi de suite à cette
autre soirée électorale
que j'aurai le bonheur de piloter le 7
novembre prochain merci beaucoup au
revoir merci